60 minutes correspondent John Dickerson
joins us at the table on day two two for
two with John Dickerson always a good
thing to sort it all out
so John anybody who has a cell phone
knows it's so easy to overhear the
conversation of when you're talking to
somebody else what is the significance
of this of this latest revelation well
also anybody with a cell phone knows you
don't have this kind of conversation on
a cell phone
talk about the irregular Channel now
which we should be clear we something
has been alleged and part of what this
process will be is nailing down all the
details of this what exactly was
discussed did somebody over here the
right thing and so forth but this is
what was important about Taylor's
testimony yesterday is there as an
allegation of another instance in which
the president appears according to his
account of it focused on the Biden's and
the Biden family why is that important
is because one half of the president's
defense and again Republicans still have
multiple defenses of the president not
all of them aligned one of the defenses
is that the president cared so much
about corruption the counter-argument is
no he cared about corruption by one
person one family and that's the family
that happens to be running against him
in this Electress is though the first
supposed connection to President Trump
himself that we're hearing in the
evidence correct how effective is this
for the Democrats well it's their
central quick case I mean because if we
go up to 30,000 feet the the fact is
that the American president has amazing
and enormous authority in foreign policy
and he's granted that by the
Constitution and the the what's at issue
here is whether he used that authority
for himself or for the country and if
he's talking about the Biden family he's
using it for himself is the allegation
from the Democrats and so that's why
it's central to their case but I've
heard the Republicans say listen there
was no investigation of the Biden's that
Ukraine did in fact get the aid so
really nothing to see here well that's
their strongest argument because we
should remember when we think about this
there are sort of three ways to think
about evidence here one is whether it
builds a case for impeachment one is
whether it gives Republicans enough
evidence to go to their constituents and
say whatever they need to say to get
reelected which is really I mean let's
be honest in politics that's what this
is about is whether you can you can
justify your vote one way or the other
and then finally we have to think about
this in the election context because
we're thinking about the presidency as
this evidence comes
whether it's worth giving the president
another four years so for Republicans
trying to just get to an argument about
what's happening that's a strong point
but in law I haven't found a lawyer who
has said if you try to commit some kind
of illegal act it's okay if it doesn't
succeed so there's no there's no lawyers
says that in the Nixon case he was
driven for office for things he wanted
to do but that didn't weren't carried
off and Republicans were right to not
use that standard when they investigated
people who wanted to undermine the Trump
election well Donald Trump was elected
but that wouldn't stop the investigation
into people who tried to undermine that
election so it's a it's a good political
argument for the moment but it doesn't
necessarily hold up all the way through
any evidence yet that any of this has
penetrated the public no none I don't
think for the moment but but we might
not expect it to you know there should
be a high bar from each Minh and for the
the challenge for Democrats is to put
together this puzzle make sure each
piece has integrity and that's gonna
take a long time the fact that they got
one interesting piece about this phone
call is good for them as they try to
build this long case but we got a long
time to go before those minds are
changed there's a lot to sort out here
John thank you for more on the key
testimony and what's ahead in the
impeachment inquiry we invite you to go
to our web sites at CBS news.com slash
impeachment